all right here's the first story we got
from The Daily Mail breaking news
Memphis cops released horrific video
five officers reigning punches and kicks
down on Tyree Nichols is that it
pronounce it Tyree Nichols I was calling
him Tire nickels before I couldn't tell
you because like if it was Tyree I think
it'd be like two e's but I'm not trying
to get his name wrong what's the Tyree
as he screams out mom before dying in
hospital after cardiac arrest and kidney
failure so
they got a bunch of different angles
they pepper spray them they pin them on
the ground there's surveillance footage
where he's got his hands behind his back
they're holding I think they've cuffed
him at this point right yeah I think so
and then the cop just walks up and just
does full boom boom just starts wailing
you see him going back and forth yo it's
tough to watch yeah it's very tough to
watch and they had that uh that doc uh
I'm sorry the chief of police came out
earlier and said it's as worse or as bad
or worse than Rodney King and so I'm
kind of just like yo do they want people
to write it tonight because they want
the rights because they want they've
been hyping it up all week and then
she's like we wanted to release the
footage on a Friday when no one was in
school or at work so it wouldn't be
disruptive it's just like so you want to
make sure everyone is available in the
protest exactly they did the Mike Brown
non-indictment announcement on a Friday
night too if I recall it's like right at
this exact time it's it's like they want
people to Riot yeah I think they do that
there was that uh the fire bomber the
antifa fire bomber in New York one year
in prison the judge even praised the
dude the judge was like you're a good
guy you know you've done a lot of great
things you're going to go far away for a
year and it's just like this guy
firebombed a police vehicle and him and
his friend were giving out fire bombs
and one year meanwhile some like Bumble
and Bumpkin walks into the Capitol
Building confused and you're like 20
years in prison I'm exaggerating by the
way but like you know they that Viking
man got four that's a good who did
viking man got for it oh right he's like
he was a guy who's just like doofing
about he didn't do anything yeah he just
trespass four years in prison meanwhile
fire bomber welcome to America we can
have a I mean we were talking about the
other day like are we in for another
Summer of Love it's like it's still
winter man I'm kind of feeling like
summer Love's coming it seems like it I
could go for an actual Summer of Love at
this point how about you guys what does
that mean like where we actually love
each other again trying to take care of
each other I mean I'm not down with
violence though you break something you
buy it man you wreck somebody's house
you're you're threatening their
livelihood in their life at that point
we talked about this the other day I
think I don't know if we talked about on
the show but uh we're talking about how
property rights are uh
life rights like the root of property
rights is your ability to live safely
and securely that's why you can own land
and you can farm and grow food if if you
are like I am going to work all year to
grow food and then some Communists
jumping they're like it's not yours it's
ours well then nobody has security and
if they kick you out of your house if
they if they burn your house down you go
out in the and it's cold outside you'll
die from hypothermia like there's no
juice no joke your home is your is the
is the central Nexus of your livelihood
now I did the unthinkable today I
watched a lot of MSNBC and CNN just to
kind of see you just see what everyone
well it's like all they're talking about
is this this one person and him dying
and and it's almost like they're just
feeding into it they're making the scene
like this is the biggest story in the
country when in fact it's one of
thousands of murders that happen every
month in this country like that's what
like if this worst case scenario these
cops did it they murdered them they're
like you said I think they did they're
already in jail like these videos what
else do you want besides them getting
arrested like what are you protesting
for protesting is
that's exactly what it is but they're
not saying that but that like so when
when Biden gets out there and he said he
actually said like we want you to
protest peacefully why are you
protesting at all protesting what they
were already arrested they're in jail
what else do you want but yeah exactly
this is it that they they know that
abolish the police is unpopular but
that's really what they want you got a
video I gotta say like I watched the
surveillance footage and I'm just like
yeah there's no justification for having
a guy in cuffs who's just standing there
and then you start wailing on his face
yeah always bad yeah it was
uncomfortable I haven't seen the video
is it too graphic I don't think we can
play it on YouTube so was he saying
something and then they came up behind
him you said too much kind of thing no
like he was like he was dizzy
disoriented they just kept hitting him
like and it seemed almost personal like
very personal like I'm sure there's more
to it well Cindy you didn't deserve it
don't get me wrong but it seemed like
the either the cop has roid issues or
something something wrong with that guy
well I'll just say I probably probably
shouldn't say it but I want to you're
talking about the Super Chat the Super
Chat where someone said there's a rumor
that he was banging a dude's wife or
something like that yeah more than it
was personally yeah but but I only say
that because you said it looked like it
was personal and I felt the exact same
way like when they got the deuce of guy
subdued and then the dude walks up and
just winds up and goes boom boom I'm
like does he know that guy right because
that's not I like the all the videos
we've seen of cops
when they're like detaining or arresting
someone you can tell what they're doing
and why they're doing it like a lot of
these videos are stop resisting and then
they start hitting them and punching
them in the head but that's like they
call it pain compliance this looks like
Revenge yeah it's like that one guy in
particular it's not like yeah yeah
you're doing it yup he looked like in
Mortal Kombat when it's like you finish
him yeah that's what he looked like and
then so that one cop was the one who
kept yeah it was only the one cup and I
know there was one uh I don't know if
there was also a part of it where
they're hitting with an eye stick I
don't know if that was like the same
copy whatever you know it could be that
this rumor emerges because people people
are like does this guy know him yeah you
know it's a good point they're trying to
fill in the gaps I mean Memphis is like
one of the most violent cities in the
country and so if we were trying to have
a hotbed for cultivating
um an anti-police sentiment it might be
one of the places to do so because I'm
sure there are a lot of people there who
feel as though the justice system is
against them and you know hurts everyone
they know I think it's the obvious
parallels you're gonna see here that you
know this man was stopped uh it was it
started as a traffic stop and there are
cities like Philadelphia that have tried
to do away they try to get rid of any
chance of having a traffic stop to avoid
this kind of Confrontation or a
confrontation escalating uh the video is
I mean I think the video speaks for
itself but obviously if we find out
later that there is some sort of social
or relationship some sort of connection
between the men like I don't think it
makes it better I think it's just it
probably speaks to more systematic
issues in Memphis yeah it could even
indicate like premeditation the guy
knows the guy and he sees him across and
he walks towards him to hit him that's
very different than he's on him and then
he starts hitting him yeah out of
defense or or something it's just hard
to like I don't think that's true that
the guy was banging his wife I think it
just sounds Sensational it was a super
chat so yeah it's on the internet
they're foreign
so then what happened these five cops
are in jail right now because this is
like the first time they all turn
themselves in and they've all been
they've been arrested by I think they
all posted Bond last I read were they
actually over there I think they're out
but then again
I wonder where they are right now
because it sounds like Memphis is not
the place to be is that riots right now
it I mean I don't know about right now
but it seems like there's a chance that
tonight is a night for it yeah I mean
Colin was watching footage I don't know
where he was watching but there's
definitely people out on the streets
there are demonstrations but I don't
know if it's escalated oh yeah yeah this
this there's like a YouTube video from a
day ago was Tyree Nichols having an
affair with one of the officers wives
and they found him and they were like so
I typed in so I picked up Google I typed
in Tyree Nichols and it auto filtered a
fair Reddit and I was like whoa what so
I clicked it and just gave me a bunch of
Reddit posts about the story so I got
rid of Reddit so it says Tabernacles
Affair and there's a video where a guy
sang it from yesterday so maybe it was
someone just speculating I don't know
because people are trying to people like
why would the cops do this is like is
the cop just a murderer and he was just
feeling like killing a guy or was there
a reason for it
it's pretty rare I think most murder I
don't know I don't actually have the
data to back because of most murder is
between people that know each other is
that true and I think a lot of the cops
are just uh they see
the mental aspect of being a cop like
they see dead bodies all the time like
they come across a car accident they see
them they're the first to see a dead
body they have to call People's loved
ones these people a lot of police I
think are suffering from mental health
issues and they're messed up in the head
what I saw in that video I mean that's
that man has serious issues like anger
issues he's probably seen a lot of
things Memphis is a dangerous city he's
working a lot of dangerous areas and I'm
not justifying anything he did obviously
he needs to be held responsible for that
but what you saw in that video is not
normal anger an accountant doesn't have
that kind of anger in them somebody that
actually sees crazy on a daily
basis like that's what I saw in that
video so what's your prescription are we
going to get a summer love
oh yeah we're gonna I mean well luckily
it's winter so we got that going I mean
look look this stuff's already starting
in January I mean normally we wait until
the springtime when people start coming
out but people are protesting in Winter
which you know it's almost like the
groundhog see his shadow like did the
protesters come out in winter because if
they do then they're then they're heated
up
yeah it's a lot of it I think is
desperation with this economic downturn
I'm really we need some sort of like uh
industrial Revival or revolution in this
country but like why do we know but like
so one guy in in Memphis was murdered
right so but people are murdered across
the country on a daily basis and this is
what annoys me about this is that this
is what the media and politicians
Democratic politicians tell us is
important this is the biggest story but
it's really not because people get
murdered every day in this country in
Massachusetts the other day I don't know
if you guys heard about this one of the
most horrible stories I've ever heard a
mother
um a nurse a delivery nurse at Mass
General Hospital murdered her three
children or I saw the story and and then
tried to kill herself by jumping out of
the window to me that is so much of a
bigger story than this because the
problem that caused her to do that is
mental health and that isn't something
that we are not right but you don't
protest that right but why aren't like
you never hear calls to like let's do
something about the mental health system
here's my plan to fix the mental health
system so many people are dying in this
country every year because of mental
health that's an actual problem that is
a solution that can be fixed whereas
what are these people trying to fix
they're already in jail there's not a
problem to be fixed here five bad cops
did something bad and they're being held
they look at the police and say the this
is going to keep happening so long as
you have a police department and with
the women killing your kids people are
going to be like what should we do yeah
you make a good point a lot of the mass
shootings are people that have are on
psychiatric some sort of psychoactive
drug and what's the first thing they try
to do after they'll try and ban guns
gonna take away guns instead of go at
the pharmaceutical companies that are
profiting off of shoving drugs down
people's throats instead of fixing their
diets and you know it's like the thing
about demonizing police is it stresses
out the people that are on the force the
police force and then when they're out
there they're more stressed and then
they become more likely to get agitated
on the job so like or or fearful
resulting in an escalation of force
absolutely absolutely you know hate that
is not going to make these people fight
less right I think they see defund the
police as like a very simple solution
right cops are killing people if we get
rid of them those are gone and I think
it becomes harder to talk about mental
health like I think I think you're
totally right mental health would should
be a a bigger push in this country and
in fact what when you start talking it
made me think of there's a wave of
different families over the Christmas
time who were all involved in murder
suicides right like these very large
families I think they're two in Utah but
mental health is more complicated right
you mentioned diet we could talk about
medication we could talk about
environmental stress like it's much
harder to pinpoint a fix on one thing
whereas if I say well if cops killed
someone we should just get rid of all
cops it becomes much easier for people
to all jump on board it's not that I
advocate for that solution it's just
that like it's it markets itself better
you know what I mean and so even though
it's misdirected I think it's much
easier to push people towards that cause
or that that effort now I just want to
point out uh all these cops that got
arrested they were all black so does
that remove the racial components do you
read van Jones today what do you say oh
he said that his white it's internalized
white supremacy you got to see the
headline I screenshot it uh somewhere
you would think it satire but it's
actually real life I think it was the
guardian had one I think the guardian
here's the headline
um opinion the police who killed Tyree
Nichols were black but they still might
have been driven by oh come on man like
CNN I know I got it right here and I'm
trying to be like I'm trying to be like
can we can we point out that there the
protesters are angry with the policing
system and it's not just a race thing
and no they can't they can't help it
they can't they're they're opponent
Bixby it's it's a it's a Dave Chappelle
Clayton Bixby yeah literally like how
did they not laugh I was kidding about
earlier the guy writing that headline
trying to stay on message
we had the hot Taps here hotep Jesus
Uncle holds up Canon hotep these are uh
you know three adult black males and I
just pointed out to him I was like you
know it's funny is that because your
guess is politics you're all white
supremacist but surge over here is
African-American because he's from South
Africa quite literally it's just like
the logic yeah right like Elon exactly
Luke Luke is uh Luke he's Polish person
of color so that makes him a person of
color how come uh Slavs are considered
people of color I always wonder about
Portuguese according to welkness because
the woke don't believe white means your
skin color it means political like
dominant force or something and because
ukrainians Polish people or whatever and
like Romanians are in like a worse off
economic position right the blonde hair
blue-eyed Lou gradkowski according to
the Coalition for communities of color
they say he is a person of color now I
see a through line here and they say
hotep Jesus a black man is a white
Supreme whiteness whiteness and the
patriarchy are kind of hand in hand I do
believe it comes from the Roman slave
state it was essentially the Romans were
racist genocidal Maniacs that would
conquer and murder and enslave other
people that weren't pure blood Roman
they were like the Nazis of the time if
the Nazis had won and conquered the half
the planet
yeah it wasn't just the Romans but the
Roman patriarchy the Roman the church
that they created like has done such
damage in the amount of slavery that
they imposed on people and and it still
is like bled through into our society we
have like white Roman Heritage but it's
like it's not the skin color that's
where we that's where it exactly it
starts to get blurry we got to look past
the skin color and look at the actual
patriarchy the we even call ourselves
Patriots like that's a male dominant
thing they say God is a man that's male
dominant crap it doesn't have to be like
that you know he's going full feminist
yeah I was gonna say I don't think I
agree with you no one you don't have to
well I think part of this I think it's
easy to say like oh it's one group that
had this terrible system but like let's
remember that when the Romans had slaves
so did tons of other people right like
we are saying that oh because we are
tied to Romans and they had slavery
therefore this through line is there but
that's not true because you'd have to
say it for all civilizations right and
every descendant of a culture that had
slave would in that idea have the same
fault right I think when we talk about
patriarchal culture uh it becomes easy
to again say that there is one problem
right that men are too aggressive and
that men don't do this and whatever and
I I think that's not true personally
right I think that there are faults with
some Patriot dominated societies but I
don't think being tied to your heritage
and typically Heritage is traced through
the masculine line of your family is bad
right I think we have a better
understanding of our history and again
typically that's tied through the male
dominated line you have a better a way
of looking at the faults in your culture
right it becomes more difficult for left
on yourself thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time